In a few minutes, I'm going to show you
a video interview that I conducted with
a Catholic priest in Nigeria where we
discuss the current situation which most
people, presumably you as well, are
unaware of if you've been following the
supposed media, both liberal and
conservative. There we go with those
words again. But before I do so, let me
tell you how this all started, how I got
to uh know this priest, and how this
interview came about. About a month ago
in August, I received an email from a
Catholic charity group that was helping
Christians in Nigeria. And it said, "I
have some very sad and distressing news
and I was hoping that you might be able
to help. The news media is not covering
this topic and Catholics in Nigeria are
not sure how to seek out help. Father
Samuel Maria from Nigeria, a native and
pastor of over 10,000 souls, has just
informed me that the Muslims have been
advancing for months and are very close
to them and things are getting very
desperate. Their situation is becoming
very dire and he would like to do
another interview with any US media that
would like to hear an update
specifically regarding how the Muslims
are advancing and killing innocent
souls. As you know very well, it is not
polit politically correct today to speak
out against the Muslims and thus many
news media do not want to hear or report
what is going on. I essentially agreed
to have an interview with Father um Abba
Samuel Maria's name and we set a date
for sometime in uh in September. About a
week later, I I received another email
uh from that same person um of that
Catholic charity. And in it, they quoted
Father Abba Samuel Maria himself in in
an email he wrote to them. Uh so he
wrote on August 13th the following
quote, "Saul's Parish, Ayatwir Rectory,
which I sacrificed everything to build,
was set ablaze by fani jihadists
yesterday. The church windows glasses
were broken and the people successfully
sacked from their ancestral homes. Kudos
to the Nigerian army for successfully
disarming the people and making them
vulnerable to their attackers. The cries
of the people echo through the land as
the fani invaders equipped with logistic
and highle intelligence provided by the
military personnel attack and
slaughtered unarmed civilians in their
sleep, leaving a trail of blood flowing
like a river. Justice, integrity,
dignity, humanity, all lost in the fray.
A nation's future uncertain each passing
day. Um, and then the person who emailed
me after quoting this from the priest
said, "Please let me know if you can do
an interview with father on this topic
ASAP or uh have you any other ideas on
how to bring awareness to the crisis
they're certain they're currently
experiencing." We greatly appreciate it
as he is remaining faithful in these
diabolical times, trusting in our Lord
and our blessed mother for the triumph
of her immaculate heart. Okay. Um and
again for the record, just so everyone
knows, I'm not Catholic. Uh this is a
Catholic group of course and a Catholic
priest that I'm going to speak to. But
whether you're Catholic or not doesn't
change the facts that you're going to be
hearing about what's happening there.
But then before we could have our
interview on September 11th,
the same priest uh Father Abba Samuel um
sent an email to the person who was
writing to me saying that they had been
they had received in Arabic a Muslim
jihad declaration essentially. And uh
here it is. He they actually he had
people translate it. So it says uh uh
quote here's a quote translation of
pamphlet written in Arabic and
distributed in select mosques in
northern Nigeria by the fani nationalist
movement and this letter was apparently
dated February 6th 2025.
And in this letter it says the battle is
getting closer. We call on all true
Muslims. This is the time to act. This
is the time for second holy war. We
started in 1804. The British stopped us.
We we must regain the territories lost.
It is against Islam to rotate power with
infidels. Forget about elections that
will only lead to sharing of power.
Think of the kingdom that we shall rule
forever. We must take the enemies in the
west central and the north. Uh they mean
in Nigeria by surprise because most
Muslims live in the north. So they want
to attack the enemies mostly Christians
in the west central. That is the plot.
disperse and occupy their homes,
forests, streets, schools, markets, and
act as spies. You will suffer in this.
Rain, cold, and dust will will pour on
you. But heaven will honor you after the
inevitable battles. Our attacks on the
infidels must be total and overwhelming.
We must begin by instilling fear in
them, weaken their resolve through
kidnaps, brutal rapes, making it
difficult for them to farm and subdue
them before the war. Our strategies
involves learning from the tactics of
the past and merging it with the wisdom
of the mo of the moment. There is no
going back. Nigeria is our own. It was
handed over to us by Allah. How then can
we share what is ours? We must never
fight a defensive war. We must take the
battle to the homes of the infidels. We
must use everything that we have.
Whether you are a boy, a lady, a man, or
a woman. All Muslims of fani origin must
take this as a duty. We must sharpen our
fighting weapons. Everything is a
weapon. Your okada, knives, hands, the
trailers you drive, the tankers with
fuel, food you sell, the house of the
infidels that you guard. study very well
and wait for our order. Exploit the
weaknesses of the infidels. They're
lousy, lack discipline, sleep like
fools, love parties and dances, lack
focus, mostly unobservant and unarmed.
With your vantage position, you can take
on a whole family of 10. Conquer and
kill them if need be. The m the battle
must be fought in their homeland. The
middle belt must be totally crushed.
They are few and divided. Never trust
anyone in the east and south which is
Christian majority. Not even their
filthy Muslims who do who do everything
Allah rejects. Get yourself prepared.
The battle is near. What this is saying
is basically even the Muslims who live
amongst Christians in those areas in the
south and the center are infidels too
because they live amongst Christians. So
you can kill them as well. And then the
email that sent this to me ended up by
saying please circulate to all Christian
groups urgently so awareness would be
created and prayers continu continuously
made for the land.
Okay. So you will now see the interview
that I conducted with Father Abba Samuel
Maria and first of all unfortunately
because he was uh the interview he was
on location in Nigeria that's where he's
from the connection was very bad and so
what ended up happening is we had a
third party helping uh record it and I
couldn't even hear what he was saying.
So un but but you'll see what he says.
everything is actually put together. But
I tell you that because um what I ended
up doing is just asking various
questions and then everything was added
on uh later even though I couldn't even
hear it or see it at the time. And uh so
I tell you that because you'll hear him
speaking very passionately about very
very important and horrific stuff and
then the screen will come to me and I'm
basically kind of nonchalant and I just
ask another question. So that's the
reason I didn't even know um I'm only
seeing it now the entire video. And so
first I urge you to listen very
carefully to this man. This is a man who
is in the middle of the fray. Okay? This
is what's really happening where Muslims
are actually half the nation. Think
about it. Nigeria is half Christian,
half Muslim. At this point, Muslims
don't need to play the uh, you know,
victim card as they do in the West. And
it's a full-blown non-stop jihad. As
you'll see in the intro, I speak a
little bit about what I know has been
going on in Nigeria. And I know a fair
bit. I've actually been writing a lot
about it since probably around 2011 and
I think I say this in the video. Um, but
everything that I just read to you that
is real. Okay, these fani and the fani
are these herdsmen who are also Islamic
um and full-on jihadist mentality. Um,
but you, as you will see in the video,
uh, the media won't tell you that, and
the Catholic priest affirms this, but
they do in fact raid Christian villages
in the middle of the night or when
they're in in in churches, and
completely horrific slaughter, mass,
massacres, rapes, burning churches with
Christians inside of them. This is a
very, very constant thing. Okay? So, do
pay attention. And at the same time,
remember what I said. I recently um did
a live stream about the left if you
recall and I did a little bit of uh
talking about what the left and Islam
really have in common because if the
left is just a liberal as most people
seem to think uh it never made sense,
right? Why is why why are liberals
siding with draconian Sharia Muslims? Um
but as I argue the left and Islam are
very similar in that they both are
aligned with falsehoods, different
falsehoods, okay? or a different way of
looking at it as they're both not
aligned with the truth. Okay? And so
they are allies for one another in their
massive war on the truth. Okay? Um so
keep that in mind especially as you hear
him and he's telling you the truth of
what's really happening and you ask
yourself, "How come I never heard this?
How come the media doesn't talk about
this? How come Fox News hasn't told me
about this?" Okay? Why do the
conservative so-called media waste more
time talking about pronouns as if that's
the real problem at stake when people
are actually being burned alive and
killed and hacked to pieces with
machetes almost on a daily ba on a daily
basis actually. And if you want to learn
more about what's happening in Nigeria,
you should consult my monthly muslim
persecution of Christians report
published by the Gatesstone Institute
where I basically coate the sorts of
persecution Christians experience um at
the hands of Muslims every month. And by
far the worst is going to be Nigeria as
you'll see. And these go back all the
way to 2011. You can find them on my
website or the Gatesstone Institute. And
without any further ado, here's the
video. Welcome everyone. I'm uh joined
by a great guest and to talk about a
very important topic that very few
people in the West, especially in
America, know. Um it's an important
topic because it deals with the genocide
you've never heard about. Um and um he
is Father Abba Samuel Maria and he's a
Catholic priest in Nigeria. And before
we get going, I'm just going to have him
introduce himself uh in a couple of
minutes. Have it father.
>> Thank you very much Mr. Raymond Ibraim
and we are very very appreciative for
the wonderful work you are doing to
create awareness on the terrible
situation we are facing here in Nigeria.
I am father Samuel Maria Abba from
originally dasis but in 200
in 200
um 20 after the pandemic of the the
so-called pandemic of the covid-19 I
began the congregation of the sacred and
immaculate hearts of Jesus and Mary
congregation where we keep the
traditional Catholic mass and faiths and
moras of our one holy tried and
apostolic faith of the Catholic Church.
So I thank Mr. Raymond Ibrahim for this
interview.
>> Thank you very much, Father Aba. Um so I
will begin by telling you and the
viewers what I know about the situation
in Nigeria which I've actually been
following for probably since at least
and um I look forward to you like I said
correcting or confirming and then
elaborating on the important points. So
what I recall with Nigeria is basically
it's half it's half Christian half
Muslim. That's the way it's usually
portrayed. And um the Muslims generally
seem to be in the northern region and
the Christians generally seem to be in
the southern region. And in the northern
region you have various forms of Sharia
law and so forth and it's not exactly
ideal for Christians to live in the
north. But I think Nigeria sort of came
in the spotlight somewhat in the
international scene with the rise of Boo
Haram. um back in the like I said 2010
or or whatever. And they are of course
an Islamic terrorist organization which
definitely targeted and massacred and
slaughtered and killed Christians and
bombed and blew up their churches. Many
of them, dozens, I would say actually
because I write reports every month
about the persecution of Christians
around the Muslim world. It's very clear
Nigeria is apparently the absolute
worst. Okay, at least when it comes to
the numbers of Christians who are being
killed and just being persecuted and
churches being attacked. Um, anyway,
that went on for a long time until
somehow maybe like I don't know 5 10
years ago, all of a sudden it became the
fani herdsmen who started now taking up
the the slaughter of Christians. Okay.
And but the narrative changed. So now
the boo haram from my perspective seem
to somehow fade in the background. We
don't hear too much about them engaged
in acts of terror as as before, but the
acts of terror are greater than ever.
Um, and now they're at the hands of
these so-called fani herdsmen who I I
believe they're the vast majority of
them are are Muslim. Okay? And um, it
seems to me from what I read between the
lines, they are also uh, radicalized by
Islamic ideology. They believe what
they're doing is jihad. They enter
Christian uh settlements and villages
usually in the middle of the night or
after or on Saturday night right before
you know church and they slaughter and
kill and devastate and burn. Um and a
lot of them according to witnesses
scream things like alohar and it's very
clear they're radicalized. Okay. But in
the west the narrative is that these
fani have nothing to do with Islam
Islamic radicalization or anything. that
this is all a land dispute that it that
the fani have been driven out of their
homes due to climate change and that
they are not in any way shape or form
ideologically motivated against let's
say Christians. In fact, they try to
blur the line and they won't even say
one's Muslim or one's Christian. It's as
if uh it's sedentary people versus
nomadic herdsmen. But of course, it
seems to me the nomatic herdsmen are
mostly Muslims and the sedentry are
Christians. And of course, I think
Muslims who live among the Christians
get killed too. their collateral damage
uh and so forth. So that's uh that's the
general gist that I've seen and um I'm
I'm frankly shocked and disgusted at the
Western media, but like I said, you'll
correct me and the analysts and I've
seen many people from Hillary Clinton,
Bill Clinton, the Obama administration,
all of them talking about, you know,
what's happening has nothing to do with
religion at all whatsoever. Okay? It's
something else. It's like I said um
climate change you know and to his
credit for I even remember um Donald
Trump when he was president in the first
term with Muhammad Buhari he asked him
why are you killing Christians and uh
you know to his credit at least he
brought that question up and that's the
other point I hear that the the
government whether it's Boohari or not
is somehow complicit. they either turn a
blind eye when the Muslim when the fani
are killing and destroying or they or or
sometimes they're there and they don't
help at all or sometimes I've even heard
they help the the terrorists. Okay, so
that seems to be the situation for me
and I've read statistics like in Nigeria
something like one Christian is killed
every two hours because of their
Christian identity. Okay. So, um that's
the summary that someone like me who's
moderately educated
by American standards regarding Nigeria,
we never hear about this. Okay. Here in
America, I I often point out you maybe
you're familiar with uh you know
something like black lives matter in
America and people always say black
lives matter, but um I've often pointed
out they don't matter obviously if
they're in Nigeria and if they're
Christian. Um, so yeah, I'll hand it
over to you now and uh you can like I
said elaborate, confirm or refute
anything I said.
>> So it's quite interesting because it's a
jihad. I I got this um information
um just some few days ago about the
national fani movement dated February
6th, 2025.
The battle is getting closer. We call on
all true Muslims.
This is the time to act. This is the
time for second holy war. We started in
1804.
In the early 19th century, they started
this particular jihad. The British
taught us we must regain the territories
lost. It is against Islam to retain
power with incidence. Forget about
election that will only lead to sharing
of power. Think of the kingdom that we
shall rule forever. We can change the
naughty history.
Usman Danfodio,
he was the one that began the jihad did
it successfully. We can do it too. We
must take the enemies in the west
central and the ins by surprise. That is
a plot. Disperse and occupy their homes,
forests, streets, schools, markets, and
act as spies.
You will suffer in this. Rain, cold, and
dust will pour on you, but heaven will
honor you after the inevitable battles.
Their kind of heaven, of course. Our
attacks on the infides must be total and
overwhelming. We must begin by
instilling fear in them, weakening their
resolve through kidnaps, brutal rapes,
making it difficult for them to farm and
subdue them before the war. This exactly
is what they are doing and they are
still doing it.
The write up continues, "Our strategies
involves learning from the tactics of
the past and merging it with the wisdom
of the moment. There is no going back.
Nigeria is our own. It was in it was
handed over to us by Allah. Of course,
not the God I worship. Allah is not the
trinitarian God."
And that's why it's so sad to see what
the Vatican is doing with the Muslims in
recent times. How then can we share what
is ours? We must never fight a defensive
war. The Calibious countries of Nigeria
are fighting a defensive war. Whereas
these people are ransacking and taking
over villages, raping, taking over lands
and territories, farmlands. People are
living in constant fear. Everybody is
worried. Everybody's afraid. And we are
not allowed to take up arms to fight for
ourel. The government, the military par
status are all taken over by these
particular sets of jihadists. They are
everywhere in government. They are the
free masons. They are the ones in
control of the Nigeria economy, the
Nigeria army, the Nigerian politics and
so on and so forth. The reading
continues, "We must take the battle to
the homes of the infiders. We must use
everything that we have. Whether you are
a boy, a lady, a man or a woman, all
Muslims of fani origin must take this as
a duty. You must sharpen our fighting
weapons. Everything is a weapon. Your
okada, that's the riding the the
motorcycle, your knives, your hands, the
trailers you drive, the tankers with
fuel. Food you sell. It's alleged that
most food gotten from them these days
are poisoned and this poisonous food
goes ahead to kill. They know what it
is. They identify it and they give it to
the infiders according to them and
people die in their numbers. The houses
of the infidels the reading continues
that you guard because most of them they
work as um security men in people's
houses. Study very well and wait for our
order. Exploit the weakness of the
infides. They are lousy. They lack
discipline. They sleep like fools. Love
parties and dances. Lack focus. Mostly
unobservant and unharmed. See this is
the reason why whenever they strike
people cannot defend themselves because
they come when you are least expecting.
Sometimes people are in the churches.
They come they burn the churches. Burn
the people in the churches. It is a
jihad and they are serious and people
are dying in their numbers. With your
vantage, the reading continues,
position, you can take on a whole family
of 10. Conquer and kill them if it need
be. The battle must be fought in their
homeland. The middle belt must be
totally crushed. They are few and
divided. Never trust anyone in the east
and south, not even their filthy
Muslims. Now this is those people who
claim to be Muslims in the west and also
in the east and in the south. They don't
consider them as true Muslims. You are
either fooling Muslims or you are
infidel. Not even their filthy Muslims
who do everything Allah rejects. Get
yourself prepared. The battle is near.
So they ask that this should be
circulated around Christians. So it is
clear Mr. Ibraim in his research is not
wrong. What he's saying is a fact. We
are witnesses to it. Just last month,
they went to Yellow.
It's not too far from where we are here.
It's just a 20 minutes drive. They
ransacked the whole village. Even
the 14th committed on this the next day.
Ransack the whole village, burn people
alive, run away and not a single
corporate have been caught.
And very close to Elwata, we have the
army barak. Still close to Elwata, we
have the eos barak. We have the nava
barak. So how come the strike and they
go? Because they are the ones in control
of those barracks. So whatever he's
saying is the truth and people are
shying away from it and souls in their
numbers are being killed. Villages are
being ransacked. People's life are being
wasted.
It's terrible. It's very very terrible.
And it's sad that the Nigerian
government is quite about it. For crying
out loud, who's the Nigerian government?
The Nigerian government is them. They're
in politics. They're in economy. They're
even the one deciding what should take
place in the country. So, it is sad and
I think only the Lord can help us now.
That is why we at SSIH
sacred and immaculate hearts of Jesus
and Mary congregation, we are for the
reign of the sacred heart of Jesus and
the triumph of the immaculate heart of
Mary through the through the acceptance
of the true traditional Catholic mass
and the true Catholic faith and morals.
This is a crusade and with God in our
side, the sacred heart will truly reign
and immaculately heart with truly
triumph.
>> Okay, thanks for that answer, Father
Aba. Um, can you speak some more about
the question of Islamic radical ideology
and um really home in and uh focus in on
to what extent is that really behind
what's happening and um what is is it
what is being taught to the Muslims of
Nigeria for example are they being
taught that the Christians um I think I
read somewhere that they're seen as
invaders uh remnants of colonialism
hence boo haram right western education
or whatever is a is a sin haram. Um is
that how they're presented? Is it
presented as a full-blown jihad? Um you
know, to destroy and kill the infidels.
Um and what's the situation with
churches? I hear, like I said, I've been
following the persecution of Christians
by Muslims for well over since 2011,
actually. And one of my books is all
about it. Crucified Again, which came
out 2013. And I would say the the most
churches that I've seen burned and
bombed and destroyed oftentimes with
Christians in them are in Nigeria. Egypt
maybe is a close second or has been for
a while back in the 2010s and 19 or
before 2020. Um but maybe you can speak
a little to that please.
Um the average Muslims are being taught
um to be radicals
because with the result of what we are
getting currently either they are being
taught to be radicals and to see other
people in the same vicinities like
themselves as infidels.
Infidels. people who are against Allah,
against um Muhammad, against the Islamic
movement. So it is clear because they do
not recognize the fact that people exist
before they came to the country and so
for them they indoctrinate their
faithfuls and their faithful carries out
this plan. See they are very organized
and that's a fact.
So the average Muslims goes out through
their what do they call it this their
school their Islamic schools and there
they are indoctrinated
if they're related with you is with a
plan they don't come to you without a
plan and all this noise about Islam is
for peace certainly is not the kind of
Muslims we have in Nigeria
they have an agenda and that agenda is
been materialized because the killings
are going on daily and unfortunately
many villages have been ransacked.
People have taken their wares and their
businesses from the north down to the
middle bel
and now some of they are taking it back
to the easts and to the west. You see it
now. So if it's not real, these business
people and families would not have
vacated from those environments. They
want to Islamize the country. It is a
fact. It is real. And not just getting
converts. They want to force their way
through and own Nigeria as their own. So
Mr. Raymond Ibraim is not wrong. He is
in his analysis is correct. They pushing
us away. pushing us away until we get
frustrated probably look for another
country to go to because for them
Nigeria is theirs.
>> What do you think of how the west has
been handling this? Are they
intentionally the media for example
dissembling and um pretending this is
all just about uh climate change as I
pointed out earlier? Um I remember
that's actually what the Irish president
or prime minister said after one of the
worst bombings of a church in Nigeria. I
think it was Palm Sunday maybe three
four years ago something like 50 or 60
or more Christians were killed and um
and it was the fani and he came out
vehemently saying you know it's all you
horrible people how dare you blame the
fani they're innocent victims too this
has nothing to do with the religion and
then he started talking about climate
change etc. Um, so basically what's uh
is what's the situation in churches? Are
Christians when they gather in churches
essentially terrified they might be
blown up or killed seeing how common it
is?
>> Yes, it is strange to see the the
Western media um not reporting exactly
what is taking place here.
As I said earlier on, it's a jihad.
Villages are being ransacked.
Lives are being wasted in their numbers.
Now, if the media reports
4,000 persons, be rest assured about
10,000 have gone.
So, one cannot come out clearly to say
the media has been bought because we
don't know who is doing the buying.
But those of us who are here
experiencing this terrible massacre, we
are aware that villages in their numbers
are being ransacked.
So if the medians internationally have
the facilities to truly know what is
happening, why can't they report exactly
what we are experiencing here?
Because you go to a village, you burn in
the village, people's life are wasted,
people's properties, their food are
burnt and you come back after some time
and repeat the same things and nobody is
caught.
Can we say the Nigerian government don't
have what it takes to catch these
persons?
Don't we have state boundaries?
So when people some people come down our
forest our forest are they so massive
that we cannot track down people
for example look at the kidnap is going
on the same forest in Nigeria here I say
the government don't have drones to
locate these persons and bring them to
the book
or we hear every now and then we shall
get them we shall get them and nobody
gets caught
so it is terrible the media
to my own knowledge is not reporting
correctly what is happening. Either they
have been bought or they don't want to
report it or they are part of the plan.
>> What is uh Thank you for that. What
would you say? What message do you most
want to convey to let's say the western
public people in Europe in general in
the US in particular about what's really
happening in Nigeria and what how they
should respond to it? um including of
course how they've been responding and
what they've been told which I assume is
of all false.
>> It's a spiritual battle. It's a
spiritual battle and as it stands now
they are out to Islamize the whole
country not just Islamize
to wipe out Christians in Nigeria
because they were able to get their way
into the government.
The British government
felt that the northern oligarchy
were more subent
to their plan of divide and rule. And so
they consecrate they concentrated powers
to the north
because the other tribes in Nigeria
they were more or less like a democracy
especially the EOS
they are more or less a democracy.
The robbers of course they represent
they have leaders and they are very very
fetish but they're not the system of
government please the British who
colonized this country and so
when they put power in the hands of the
north with the jihadist agenda
they now concentrated themselves on this
power and began man to rule the country
ever since.
So for you to be elected into any
federal office, you must lick the boots
of the northerners. If not, you will not
get there.
So they now use these powers to
manipulate their ways to carry out their
full and near agenda of Islamizing the
country.
So this is exactly what is happening
and with this it is almost impossible to
stop them because they everywhere
all the military all the paratas all the
political they are there why because
they know what it is to rule for example
sooto where the caliphate is
is titled born to rule
That's a title against born to rule.
Born to rule who? Born to rule the rest
of Nigerians and submerge them into the
jihadist agenda.
So the west can only come in now by
telling them that Nigeria is a country
of so many religions and the freedom to
worship God, the true God
is a right of every human being and the
true God is the Catholic God. That is
why we in our own little way for the
reign of the sacred heart of Jesus and
the immaculate heart of Mary
form the society of the sacred
immaculate heart to bring about the true
reign of Christ our king and the
queenship of our lady. So it is a
spiritual battle and victory is assured.
Alut continue victoriart.
Our lady will certainly triumph and our
lord certainly reign. But for the west
what is happening in many countries in
the world if they don't come to help us
with this crisis tomorrow you will hear
that Nigeria is now an Islamic country.
>> Okay. Thank you for that very
comprehensive view. Thanks for joining
us and um I leave you with the last
word. Any final thoughts or words you'd
like to share with us are of course
welcome Mr. Raymon Ibraim who is doing
so much to see that the true story of
what is taking place in the country of
Nigeria and most African countries that
have been invaded by the fan headsmen
and the jihadic plans. You know, it's
like the crusaders when the earlier
popes were able to fight this with the
rosary and also were able to gain so
much victory. Now is a time for
Nigerians. Um it's half half the Muslims
and the Christians
and most of these lands we're talking
about they are Christian lands.
These people came in and started
invading and they took over step by
step. So they are not giving up. But
unfortunately for us down here, there is
no formidable force that will stop them
from the killings
except God intervenes.
If the n the the the international media
and the national the United Nations can
come into this problem and help us out,
it will be very very nice. But as you
can see, it's not only Nigeria that
doing this. They're doing this in most
lands. Even in Europe, they're taking
over almost every places. So it is so
it's a ser.
So if God can help us in this situation
which we know he can really help us, you
know, we will support any group that is
going about bringing about the
restoration. And that is why in our own
little way we decided to form ourselves
into groups of young men and young girls
praying before the bless sacrament
living a life of penance life of
reparation in the sight of the second
immaculate heart to bring about the
restoration
because we know that is only through God
that the peace can be gotten. Our lady
of Fatima said at last my immaculate
heart will triumph and the sacred heart
will ring. So we trust in God. Currently
we are securing the different places we
have our chapels because our chapels are
close to these areas that are possible
areas for invention. So we need help. We
need people to help us so we can secure
this land. face the land, protect the
nuns who are daily praying for us and
protect the seminarians and the sisters
who are carrying out all these means
spiritually to bring about the
restoration.
So this is what we are asking for. We
need help to carry out our programs
because almost everybody seems to be
sorry about the the the the the
insurgency that is going on. lives are
being lost and most of these lives being
lost have not received the sacrament of
baptism and it's our intention to go to
the grassroots and evangelize and bring
them to Christ bring Christ to the souls
of these people before this maruding fan
heads men will come and take them they
come and kill them and probably they go
to hellfire we don't want that to happen
so we are a formidable force that is
trying to see how we can bring about the
restoration through prayer
penance sacrifices and the celebration
of the Chentan Catholic Mass as a
reminant group in Nigeria. Thank you and
God bless.
>> Okay. Thank you, father. And thank you
everyone for joining